did you hear about the new iPhone how  cool what new features that they have  you know what it doesn't matter I'm  gonna get one anyway I know the iPhone  six bends but that just means I get to  buy another one this button is so sleek  and well designed I can't wait to put a  Hello Kitty kiss on it things aren't  cool unless you wait in line for them  everything else I am is by Apple there's  no going back now they've got us right  where they want us yeah I may not be the  best phone anymore but easier to use  something that I already know and that's  good enough for me  these are my collectors items you know  how those things are made right yes and  I don't like to think about it  this phone is so much more important to  me than my car I'm unemployed but that  didn't stop me from getting an iPhone 6  great and here's a check for $40 and a  cookie Wow cool